hi I'm Kristen Goodwin on this episode
of the Fox News rundown journalists
continue to deliver the hard-hitting
headlines stirring unprecedented times
Bill Hemmer host of Bill Hemmer reports
on the Fox News Channel and the podcast
hammertime joins host Jessica Rosenthal
to discuss what it's been like covering
the corona virus pandemic an economic
crisis and a contentious presidential
election he also weighs in on why he is
optimistic about America's future
restaurants and bars are among the
hardest hit businesses amid the outbreak
Liliana LaValle founder of the famed
coyote ugly saloon in New York City
joins host Chris Foster to discuss why
some of her venues might not recover
Plus commentary from Fox News
contributor cat Tim the Fox News rundown
is a Daily News podcast where we take a
deeper look at the stories important to
you you can subscribe on your favorite
podcast player by going to FoxNews
podcast.com Dora barrel I'm Emily
Campania and I'm Eric Sean this is a Fox
News Rhonda
Wednesday May 20th 2020
I'm Jessica Rosenthal things may be
different for a while
thanks to this virus but some see better
days ahead especially now that we've
been tested I think if there is another
way or two or three I think we are much
better prepared then anyone could have
suggested in the first week of March I'm
Chris foster a OD ugly saloon owner
Liliana Lovell says some of her bars
might not survive the corona virus
outbreak this has been very difficult
bars that were successful may not reopen
because we haven't come to terms with
with you know the entities that hold our
leases and it's this is a lot to handle
and I'm cat Tim I've got the final word
on the Fox News rundown
as people wait to go back to work and
hope there are jobs to go back to
president Trump indicated that's a
priority because with millions of
Americans forced out of work by the
virus it's more important than ever to
remove burdens that destroy American
jobs in a few minutes I will sign an
executive order instructing federal
agencies to use any and all authority to
waive suspend and eliminate unnecessary
regulations that impede economic
recovery he said he was disappointed in
China but said it just proves his
long-standing insistence on the
importance of bringing supply chains
back to the US it's a disgrace could
have been stopped at the source but they
decided not to do that
but we're going to safely we open our
country and our economy and it's
happening very rapidly
he said states like Florida and Georgia
are reopening without a spike in virus
cases however parts of Texas North
Carolina and Arizona have seen increases
meanwhile the financial attempts to prop
up the economy through the pandemic were
questioned by the Senate Banking
Committee this week Treasury Secretary
Stephen minuchin testified about the
money meant to help families and
businesses so far there have been snafus
with programs like the Paycheck
protection plan larger companies getting
money they ended up giving back and
smaller businesses not getting much of
anything we've issued more than a
hundred and forty million economic
impact payments for over two hundred and
forty billion to provide direct relief
to millions of Americans the typical
family of four received approximately
$3,400 but he said if states don't start
reopening there could be permanent
damage to the economy Minuten rejected
criticism from senator Elizabeth Warren
that he's propping up Wall Street by
failing to force larger companies to
hire all of their employees back both he
and Federal Reserve Chairman Jerome
Powell defended the spending so far
while Minuten leans toward a pause in
spending Powell says more stimulus may
be needed this reversal of economic
fortune has caused a level of pain that
is hard to capture in words as lives are
upended amid great uncertainty about the
future the Reserve is committed to using
our full range of tools to support the
economy in this challenging but will it
be enough to prevent a catastrophic
5% unemployment rate as people in
nursing homes or with underlying health
conditions fear the virus many younger
healthier folks are fearing their bank
accounts the pain is everywhere today is
the first day that I feel actually
somewhat normal going back to March not
that that's what I would say he is the
host of Bill Hemmer reports and the
hammer time podcast you have to remember
I cracked my fibula a couple months ago
on Easter Saturday so I've been going
through Corona with a broken ankle and
that feels better now the weather has
turned here in the Northeast I think
that has an effect and I think really on
the numbers we have had our lowest death
count for two or three days running now
across the country and I think that is a
very good sign when you start to look at
deaths we'll keep an eye on it hopefully
it stays low that way and it does not
spike but deaths and hospitalizations of
the numbers you have to keep an eye on
and some of the numbers people are
keeping an eye on our you know economic
numbers we we heard this week Fed
Chairman drom Powell told the Senate
Banking Committee while everyone did
what they did to stay home to try to
save lives
the economic impacts hit those hardest
who were least able to bear them
Treasury secretary minuchin testified he
sees good economic indicators on the
horizon and he's not going what the
president has said that we're gonna have
a tremendous year next year is that
overly optimistic I'm not sure how this
all pans out to be frank with you
my sense is that everyone's guessing
I'll give you an igloo an example I've
been on the phone with Delta Airlines
for a couple weeks it's trying to figure
out where they operate and when and I it
has been stubborn and what that tells me
is that the demand for flying is just
not there that's that that's one data
point with regard to the overall economy
I think the market is reacting in a way
than most people did not expect you know
the S&P and the Nasdaq were about where
they were before all this happened and I
think that has been confound
many what I sense is that investors
believe the comeback could happen sooner
rather than later I'm not saying they're
right but I think they're betting on
that I would also read that between
minuchin and Jerome pal the Fed chair
they have put so much money into the
system it is bound to have an effect
with regard to Congress and whether or
not they make another move I don't think
you can expect that well into June if at
all depending how this recovery goes
back to the Senate Banking Committee for
a second one one of the Senators you
know asked at one point how many people
will die as we send people back to work
and it's that it's that right that
tension between like if you want the
economy to open then you're okay with
people dying and if you're not okay with
it then you're okay with people not
having work and not being able to pay
their bills it's like this unfair choice
right and we keep hearing that
discussion but what where should we be
where do you think where do you think we
are is it look you have to weigh the
risk for yourself and we just we just
need to go back out there and sort of
lock away the nursing homes in the
senior care facilities and hope for the
best
here's my feeling and it's a very
interesting question here's what I would
say I think we know so much more now
than we did 60 days ago I think if there
is another wave or two or three I think
we are much better prepared then anyone
could have suggested in the first week
of March
Jessica unfortunately I've been in New
York City this entire time I have not
travelled I have barely left the city
sometimes alpha long island but maybe
for a day or two I would very much enjoy
the opportunity to get out and see
what's happening in Dallas what's
happening in Columbus Ohio what's going
on in Denver Colorado because I don't
get a good sense of it but I do believe
this
anytime someone sneezes in New York City
people give them a double-take any time
someone even feels as if they're running
a fever
99 degrees then there's a
you don't go to work and we can operate
under under those under those guidelines
and prevent another massive waves I'm
coming back here and knocking us off our
feet again I am optimistic and that we
are much better prepared to handle this
than we could have ever guessed two
months ago
well that's great um I want to ask you I
want to pivot for a second because you
pivoted right quick last week we went
you went from from the virus to politics
when the Michael Flynn unmasking story
broke and I know those pivots are
extreme and difficult where does this
story sort of end up in your mind we
know Attorney General Barr reminded us
of Connecticut Attorney General John
Durham's investigation into the origins
of the Russia investigation right and
criminal charges could come from that
but but Barroso said former President
Obama and Vice President Joe Biden are
not a part of a criminal investigation
the President as we know has since said
he was surprised by that does this just
become a talking point now used to put
Biden on defense where does this go
I see III expected you know I didn't
expecting announcement but I wasn't
surprised by the statement with regard
to former President Obama and former
Vice President Joe Biden I have always
been dubious as to whether or not any of
this would lead to a criminal
prosecution I could be wrong but I do
believe and I'm not a lawyer I'm not
trained in it but I think the law has to
show intent and yet if you could do that
you could proceed with the prosecution
and probably find a way to be successful
I have I am NOT and have not been
convinced that that is the course that
the government will take and I have felt
this way since I went to El Salvador a
year ago for bill bars first interview
when I talked to him then about what he
was looking at and what he was trying to
uncover and how he talked about things
don't hang together I took the job I
started asking questions and the answers
I was getting back we're not
satisfactory okay
maybe Durham does find a way to
prosecute that but but ever since that
trip and just listening to the line
the answers he gave I have not been
convinced that anyone will be prosecuted
okay back to back to something kovat
related bill I want to ask you about
China things seem to be getting more
tense intense both Chinese officials are
basically accusing us of overreacting
the World Health Organization is on is
on defense our president is threatening
the funding that we give them and he's
written a letter to do to the w-h-o
about that and China's calling that
letter a smear are we gonna be talking
about China for a long time to come I do
believe the answer is yes and I'm not so
sure about the future for the World
Health Organization I believe it'll stay
intact ultimately I think you have to
negotiate a stronger position where you
can exact something for the money that
you're paying and if indeed the United
States is giving a substantial amount of
payments at the World Health
Organization we should get changes for
that and how you shape that as something
that that you know leaders in our
government need to figure out but I I do
believe the relationship with the World
Health Organization has changed
I believe the relationship between the
United States and China has now on
behalf of both sides we are seeing each
other as as competitors with one another
after decades in which the Chinese they
built their economy in a different way
and you know 1.2 1.3 billion people it
was 20 or 30 years ago when I was in
Shanghai or Beijing and we were talking
about a third world country and then it
moved to an emerging market and they
have a massive middle class that
continues to grow and they will have
their own demands on their own
government to make sure that they can
have jobs but I think the United States
and China have reached the point where
they are competitors for decades to come
in every category yeah it certainly
feels adversarial and the president says
China is responsible here with this
virus and needs to be held responsible
what does that look like I know some
senators want us to be able to sue China
I'm not sure if that's going to be
allowed but what in your mind does
holding them responsible I think a lot
of people frankly are obsessed
the way this relationship has gone with
the the outbreak of the corona virus and
rightly so how that relationship
develops and unfold is something that I
do not know I think for some time it
could be adversarial that was the word
you used and I don't think it'll stay
that way I think what you'll find is a
is a competition for ideas between two
countries and two economies that will
fight on their own turf to see whether
or not their policies succeed or fail in
the international community yeah and
exactly who dominates right bill one
last one in ten years are we gonna look
back on this and think the virus itself
was the big story or the economic impact
of it was I've put this over the past 20
years in the categories of the election
recount of 2010 a sea of 9/11 here in
September of 2001 of Katrina and New
Orleans the financial rack of oh wait
and no nine and I'm starting to think
that this is bigger than all of them in
a ways that so many people could not
predict not just the United States but
countries all over the world if your
question is asking me choose a or b
today I'm choosing B because this is
going to remake industries forever
in ways that we cannot predict Wow Bill
Hemmer thank you so much for your time
good to be with you Jessica
[Music]
[Music]
this is cat chimp with your foxnews
commentary
coming up there aren't many bars open in
America only in a few states including
Texas this coming weekend but only at 25
percent capacity
governor Greg Abbott says our focus is
to keep you safe while also restoring
your ability to get back to work
to open your businesses to pay your
bills to put food on your tables
Lilliana Louisville owns two bars in
Texas part of her worldwide coyote ugly
saloon Empire she opened her first
little country bar in New York City in
1993 an article led to a movie and then
openings around the world with all
female bartenders known as coyotes
showing some skin dancing on the bar and
sometimes good-naturedly abusing of the
clientele precoded we had 28 now post
kovat we are during the pandemic we have
26 it's been very interesting today I
got an email from our UK franchisee and
they don't think they'll be opening
until July or September well so they're
they're having some of the same
struggles so you know they've also
received their loans but again with the
way that they're structuring the social
distancing openings and the occupancy
--hz they're struggling because they
have big places and they don't know if
they'd be able to maintain all their
financial responsibilities on such a you
know with such a small footprint on
opening yeah that's the thing if you've
got a place that is designed and
budgeted for what's your biggest what
capacity well I would say the UK bars
are the biggest so Cardiff probably
somewhere around 15 to 20 thousand
square feet so to give you an idea New
York is about a thousand square feet so
I mean right but if you if you're run if
you run your numbers at okay X number
customers over the course of a week or a
month and then that suddenly
artificially cut in 1/4 you know cut to
1/4 or 1/2 can you make your nut or
they're gonna be bars that it's just not
gonna be profitable even when you're
allowed to open I mean we're dealing
with this the last few days so there's a
few states that are relaxing some of the
openings and we could possibly open up
this weekend and with Vuitton in
Oklahoma City and in Austin Texas
so in Oklahoma it's actually a little
bit more relaxed so I think we probably
will open there but Austin is that 25%
it just I don't see how we could open
and it not cost this morning to be open
well in part of Europe I know that some
of your places actually have sit-down
restaurants but part of your hook is
that these are that the bar bars sell
themselves as rowdy and fun and
bartenders in people's faces if you
talked about how you're gonna deal with
changing their to change the brand a
little yes yes absolutely so it's
something that we talk about on
conference calls every day essentially
because we're changing the social
dynamic that was part of our brand I
can't even answer right with none being
open right now I can't really answer how
exactly the vibe of coyotes going to
change because we're not open but we've
had to create new policies you know new
procedures I mean this has been a lot of
work to make sure that we're keeping on
top of all the state regulations and you
know trying to be safe from our
employees and our customers this is a
lot it's a lot to handle the company
took out coronavirus relief loans as
part of the cares Act passed by Congress
but then laid off all its managers and
one complained to the press Jeff wise
men is coyote ugly general counsel we
got our first loan at the Gabel 15
and within eight weeks you've got to use
the money up and we can't even open in
any of in any place so we've got four
weeks to open but we don't even have an
announced date from from state
governments to open anywhere so and then
if you used all the money and you're not
open and then you try and open with no
money
you're gonna go out of business and then
the loan becomes not forgivable because
you've closed the terms need to be
reworked you should be able to use the
money for any business purpose it
doesn't have to be it shouldn't have to
be 75% of payroll or you should be able
to use it over a longer term why does it
have to be used in eight weeks from
disbursement we can't even open so it
makes no sense
basically Treasury secretary Steve
minuchin said at this meeting with the
restaurant people did he understands and
that he thinks just a technical fix that
maybe maybe that can be worked out so
there may be hope on the horizon there
though I see you guys are I think that
you know another thing that people don't
understand so and I understand that you
know there's a different mindset with
business owners versus employees so as a
business owner we have a lot of
responsibilities and we only have one
space in the States that is owned and
operated of the New Orleans building
where the New Orleans bar is that the
rest are are leased from other people
other entities so people have this idea
that when we we were closed that was it
you know you don't owe rent you you know
that that your bills have stopped and
that's just not the case so this has
been very difficult bars that were
successful may not reopen because we
haven't come to terms with with you know
the entities that hold our leases and
it's this
is a lot to handle it's a couple dozen
landlords that you've got to work with
yes yeah and they all want to be paid
imagine that yeah well you know of
course I mean some of them can probably
sit on it for a while and some of them
probably can't because everybody up and
down the chain every the people you're
paying up and the people you're paying
down
they've all got bills to pay yeah I mean
we have to do what's what's in the best
interests of coyote ugly at each
location because they're each separate
LLC LLC's
so it's been uh Jeff has really been
doing a lot of work just just
communicate and the reality of opening
up at less than a hundred percent
occupancy is obviously not optimum for
success so this has been a lot I see
you've been selling tickets to reopening
parties hopefully when they sound like
ten literally so so what's funny is we
got slammed in this Texas paper okay
like twenty or thirty we made these
little gym towels that say you know
coyote ugly spread joy not germs I think
we sold maybe twenty or thirty of those
I set foot in your place in New York not
long after you opened it twenty wait it
was twenty seven years ago what do you
member the day yeah January 27 1993 okay
well some time not long after that I
walked into your bar for better or worse
and I've known you for an awful long
time I'm Jeff I've known you for an
awful long time and I I really hope that
this all works out I think that you know
we're starting to ramp up we're hoping
that Oklahoma opens up this weekend and
so it was very nice to feel some energy
you know some positive energy coming out
but but yes we are hoping that they
change the wording on some of these
loans and that it's more beneficial for
us to open up and and not feel so much
debt well keep your guys and girls safe
and keep your cut you can keep your
customers happy hopefully I'll see the
New York Bar in January I hope so and
we're coming up on 20 years since the
movie came up by the way which was a
little shocking to me that's right it is
because my son's 20 and he was about 8
or 9 months old when I went to her
premiere that's right
Lilliana level is the coyote ugly
founder and CEO Jeff Weisman her the
Robin to her Batman as the company's
general counsel Jeff though is good talk
to you good luck soon
[Music]
download fox news channels the five
podcast for free five of your favorite
fox news personalities discussed current
issues in a roundtable discussion get it
now on Apple podcasts Google Play in Fox
News podcasts calm Raiden review the Fox
News rundown on Apple podcasts or
wherever you listen it's time for your
fox news commentary captain what's on
your mind more than 200 celebrity
scientists and Nobel Prize winners have
signed an open letter rejecting the idea
that things should quote go back to
normal after the corona virus pandemic
ends arguing that we must instead stop
quote the pursuit of consumerism now to
be clear I'm not attacking them for
their success or even for them enjoying
it with lavish lifestyles what I am
saying however is that I can't help but
be earthed by the lack of awareness that
you'd have to have in order to sign
something like this while you're sitting
in an extravagant home after all if any
of the super wealthy people who signed a
letter had any real interest in stopping
the pursuit of consumerism they would
certainly have started with taking a
look at their own habits in that area a
letter recently published at the French
publication Lamond a states in part the
pursuit of consumerism and an obsession
with productivity have led us to deny
the value of life itself out of plants
that have animals and that have a great
number of human beings pollution climate
change and the destruction of our
remaining natural zones has brought the
world to a breaking point
many of these people such as Madonna
Robert De Niro Iggy Pop Christian
Louboutin
Penelope Cruz and Jane Fonda to name a
few are incredibly rich and famous
Madonna for example is actually totally
free to sell her multi-million dollar
mansion and give all the cash to
Greenpeace if she wanted to no one is
stopping her and actually with a net
worth that Forbes estimates that 570
million in 2019 she can probably part
with a lot of her assets and still live
far more comfortably than the vast vast
majority of us could ever imagine I'm
not singling out Madonna either because
there were a lot of people on that list
you probably haven't exactly had to
resort to eating boxed macaroni and
cheese in a while
celebrity network for example as
it's Jane Fonda's and about 200 million
oh and Robert DeNiro a cool five hundred
million perhaps what's most insane of
all is the fact that Christian
Louboutins signed this letter when it's
public knowledge that the most basic
pair of heels he sells are about seven
hundred bucks
Lubitz in doesn't hate consumerism he
lives and breathes it obsession with
material status symbols isn't just
acceptable to him it's actually his
entire business model the entire reason
why he the child of a cabinet maker and
state all mother was able to launch a
business that made a more than estimated
eighty five million dollars today the
thing is I actually think stories like
his are amazing I'm not attacking any of
these people for having success or money
far from it but Donna's worth hundreds
of millions of bucks but she's also
worked very hard and is incredibly
talented I'm serious
it's hard to believe that like a prayer
came out more than thirty years ago
because it still gets me on my feet
anytime I hear it know their money
doesn't bother me and neither does their
fame
what does bother me though is the
hypocritical bursary signaling they all
displayed in signing something like this
in fact it's hard to see it as anything
other than an insult to the intelligence
of the rest of us after all we're not
stupid and we know these people aren't
schlepping it
we know that Penelope Cruz for example
is in fact not sleeping on a bale of hay
in an abandoned barn somewhere we also
know that both capitalism and her
devotion to productivity are two major
reasons why you're rich in your famous
go ahead and live like you are you've
earned it but please at least respect
the rest of us not pretend that you're
devoted to minimalist living after all
if you really were you'd start by trying
it yourself
I'm captain
you've been listening to the Box news
rundown and stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at FoxNews
podcasts calm and for up-to-the-minute
news go to Fox news.com
[Music]
love FoxNews click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the FoxNews rundown
playlist for the latest episodes